how's it going everybody it's Warren
there is a lot of news going around this
morning about Keanu Reeves coming into
the MCU this is something that fans have
wanted for a really long time now and it
seems like we might be pretty close to
seeing that happen in fact Keanu Reeves
may be playing an MCU villain I'll break
down all the news that we know in this
video but first if you're new to my
channel I'm doing a giveaway at four
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers I
will be picking three winners and each
one will get to choose one item from the
Marvel Legends series collection so make
sure you're subscribed to my channel and
hit the thumbs up button so you can
enter the giveaway so this news comes
from the site MCU cosmic who reported
about the Eternals movie being in
development a long time ago
well the internals of being in
production turned out to be true and so
far it is reported that it will be
directed by Chloe Zhou in his rumor to
star Angelina Jolie Richard Madden and
Kumail Nanjiani and even though
everybody would love to see a
combination of John wick and Wolverine
go at it in the MCU it seems like
they're eyeing Keanu Reeves for a role
in the Eternals according to MCU cosmic
Marvel is seeking out Keanu Reeves for a
role in the Eternals and negotiations
are apparently already underway this is
in no way official yet negotiations are
still underway and he has not signed a
contract to appear in the Eternals yet
several reports not too long ago came
out and said that Keanu Reeves was being
eyed as the villain for the Eternals if
this ends up being true and Keanu Reeves
is cast as the villain for the Eternals
he could be around in the MCU for a very
long time because according to Marvel
Studios is President Kevin Feige the
turtles are going to be built up over
multiple movies in the MCU just like
they did with the Avengers but they're
not going to introduce everybody
individually they're going to start with
the Eternals as a group this is what
Kevin Feige said in an interview with
comicbook.com Eternals are one group but
we like the idea of introducing an
ensemble doing an in Samba movie from
the start as opposed to building up as
we did with the first Avengers more like
Guardians not totally but in terms of
introducing a new group of people so the
Eternals are going to be a big deal and
a pretty big franchise in the MCU and so
far has an amazing
caste and now that they want Keanu
Reeves to play a part in the Eternals
it's getting really exciting especially
if Keanu ends up playing a villain in
the MCU I think with his intensity he
could play an awesome villain that
everybody would love not too many people
are familiar with who the Eternals are
and according to Marvel Studios as
President Kevin Feige that is a good
thing in the same interview he told
comicbook.com
your reaction about not being familiar
with the Eternals is perfect because
most people weren't familiar with
guardians of the galaxy and believe it
or not there were people that were not
familiar with Avengers or with Iron Man
so for us it's finding great stories
whether people have heard of them or not
and bring them to the big screen in as
amazing a ways as we can we actually
already have one eternal that already
exists in the MCU and has been in many
movies and that is Thanos yes vanos is
actually an eternal he was just born
with a deviant gene famous his parents
are a Lars and Sue's son who are both
Eternals the Eternals were made by the
Celestials and have special abilities
which is why Thanos was as strong as he
was in Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame and now it seems like
Keanu Reeves could be joining the cast
of the Eternals again there were reports
that he could play the villain of the
Eternals and if that ends up being true
he could be the next big bad villain of
the MCU
but if he joins the cast as a part of
the Eternals group that still means he
could be in the MCU for a very long time
so he's in negotiations right now with
Marvel to join the Eternals and the MCU
let me know how excited you are about
this and let me know would you rather
see him join the Eternals as one of the
Eternals or would you rather see him be
a villain let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below and again a
reminder about my giveaway when I hit
450,000 subscribers I will be picking
three winners and each one will get to
choose one item from the Marvel Legends
series collection I'll then be doing a
big giveaway at 500 thousand subscribers
and I'll start a Twitter and Instagram
giveaway soon so all you have to do to
enter is be subscribed to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
all it took
you said it cost you everything while
crying like a baby now your